me mantenho inveja de mim fica muito
bons e que significa que quem não
significa que eu não tenho casa que eu
não tenho marido amiga tem família vai
tá mal acompanhado do que eu ela foi lá
pedir socorro
alguém foi lá ajudando dias audiência
ajudar eu falei mãe leva minha irmã por
led como e leve e moto méxico é nova ela
está morrendo irmãos a bengala
ela ficou meca de tanto gastar o tempo
dessa lei
neva médico mãe leva no méxico ela
tamanho aí no rio mas curva de gouveia
antes do tempo
nessa mesma minha mãe falou que eu sou
contrária
efe ele falou que eu sou contrária só
porque eu deixei de ser ordenada
faz quase um ano que eu decidi andar de
costa à frente não chega a lugar nenhum
a antena contra mim eu já experimentei e
de vez em quando eu do contrário a gente
tem outra razão
com drogba de costa não era mais tempo
mas eu gosto de experimentar o tempo eu
falar alto gesticular
eu acho que a gente tem que se prevenir
quem é que vai dizer que eu não posso
gritar livre que vai dizer que eu sou de
ficar sentada mais esperada das praças
não se incomodar
benê pintura ver convivência entre o
pensar e aí a pergunta a pergunta vai
ver como se ele pára pra olhar não gente
tem gente que tem dois anos ele para
olhar
não gente obtém de falar a verdade
então falou já deixei de ser bolada
eu notei pra vocês
o trecho ea peça é tempo de cleo tempos
de clã eo aberto
eu tinha acabado de participar de um de
um trabalho e eu conheci algumas pessoas
nesse trabalho que hoje fazem parte
dessa montagem e vai ficar encantada com
essas pessoas por causa do
comprometimento é muito comprometidas
muito criativas montar algo cênico
mas nem sabia direito o que era opositor
copei a gente conheceu trabalhar sem
saber direito o que vê
primeiramente o pensou pesquisamos
mantas da mulher dramaturgia e
alimentarmos quadros por exemplo um
trecho da mãe coragem de bresh depois na
hora de emitir 100 ou a moça assemelha
do prêmio marcos enfim não tá quadras e
nós já tínhamos até um meio da peça que
era donas em cima mas há alguma bem
parecido tava kyodo
para explorar aquela barreira da
dramaturgia próprio jeito e eu pensei
será que a gente não consegue criar o
dia
nós estávamos na cantina da lan já
esboçam do projeto com a equipe
eu olhei pro lado e veja a turel e aí a
gente começou a se olhar urban
parecia que a gente estava brincando de
quem se olha mãe chama ficando assim e
pra mim
o espaço se abriu para quem vive
conectada com a cleo conectando com
aqueles estudantes que estavam além com
a equipe trabalhando com a universidade
com espaço o banco maringá e foi nesta
anos história para contar mas poderíamos
contar nossa própria história existem
vozes abafadas no ar e foi que a gente
começou o trabalho tanto a cleo primeira
amante como inspiração a cleo é uma
relevante que frequenta o campus da
universidade estadual de maringá há
quase 20 anos que carrega a sua vida
dentro de uma carreta tipo mercado
procurando becos seguros para passar a
noite é resistência
já cleo foi nosso ponto de partida na
busca da autoridade e nós fomos para as
ruas nas praças de mamanguá é nós que
levamos alguns dispositivos que
intermediasse o acesso a outro por
exemplo eu fiquei deitado no meio da
praça no meio do caminho no lugar de
passagem o abraçado a uma lixeira no
boca focinho ajoelhada era expandir
branca ou sentado antônio no chão da
praça com uma garrafa de café com apenas
e uma placa com os dizeres café e
conversa durante nossas reuniões durante
vários dias
os primeiros experimentos até o chão
levo paredes removíveis se erguiam quase
palpáveis mas aos poucos os contatos
foram acontecendo o espaço entre outras
pessoas enchem estreitou o velho bairro
aluno apresentável
nem vou sentar vale o feijão café e
achei que era mãe de santo
daí e rapidamente já tirou a foto da
armada e perguntou se ela voltaria pra
ele eu falei sim volta logo é a
prostituta e esqueceu por um momento a
função falou dos filhos falou de culpa e
falou do desejo de ser o azulejista o
vendedor de algodão doce acertou café
mas você gostar de café o soube depois
mas ele falou que aceitou café porque
achou que tava precisando de atenção e
carinho
o lance é notar a show que realmente
absurdo que estava fazendo falou que sim
se nós estivéssemos no período da
ditadura militar eu já estava no
xilindró na seta ficou muito bravo
clamor isso em um aposentado me
perguntou se eu voltar mais vezes
problemas com vale na raposo tavares mas
a bolanos o poeta por um elemento o
coletivo sim pois as paredes se romperam
e nós não estávamos mais sozinhos na
sala juntos compartilhando os sonhos no
dúvida carinho e até intolerância
esse coletivo se antónio esse é o teatro
que eu acredito é que eu estou
também não experimenta um teatro do
protagonismo da vitimização do herói da
heroína é o teatro da unidade do
compartilhamento da crítica da próxima
lua crua atleta resistente e é a
ressignificação do homem para o outro é
o olhar e deixar ser olhado como essa os
baloeiros que tempos de cloud desafia é
o teatro ea rã com o espaço de
conhecimento e de troca né costa
construiu um ano
afetividade e por falar alegre feliz e
por falar em afetividade eu quero aqui
agradecer à equipe que construiu essa
essa obra que a gente tem tanto orgulho
e encarou nós temos a rachel quando na
produção
a carolina santana na dramaturgia na
assistência de direção
temos a gabriela foi o gol mesmo a
direcção temos atrás time code no
figurino um sérgio augusto na identidade
visual o gabriel dominato fazendo toda
agência de verde tinha o rafael sai
fiquemos pequena aqui que fez as
fotografias de cleo
o edge por favor é responsável pela
música eo ator nunca fiori do que na
primeira montagem trabalhou da
assistência de produção
muito obrigado